So today we're going to engage modernism where we talking principally about the
music of Igor Stravinsky.
I should also mention Arnold Schoenberg just as Verdi and Wagner were the
principal composers of opera in the 19th century.
So sharenburg and Stravinsky where the principal proponents not only of
instrumental music,
but some vocal music in the first half of the 20th century.
So we want to keep them,
uh,
carefully positioned on our radar screen here.
Igor Stravinsky,
of course,
was a Russian composer born in Saint Petersburg.
You had the dates up there on the board,
I'm sure.
Uh,
he studied with Nicholi Rimsky-korsakov who wrote one famous piece Shaharazad,
which I used to hear all the time as a kid.
Uh,
and then the caught the eye of Sergey Diaghilev.
Sergey Diaghilev was an emprasario.
What's an Empresario?
Who can tell me what an Emprasario is?
It's a fancy word for Thaddeus.
A producer.
Okay.
Think of the Broadway show.
The producers.
He simply,
I'm a producer and what the Aga Lev was producing Wa and importing into Paris
from Russia was modernist art from Russia,
modernist painting,
modernist ballet,
modernist art,
music,
and modernist opera.
So that's what we want to keep in mind with regard to segregate Diaghilev and
four Diaghilev Stravinsky composed early in his career.
Three important ballet scores and you have those titles up on the board there.
Firebird with its date,
1909,
uh,
Petrouchka 1911 and then uh,
the rite of spring in 1913.
Now the first of these ballets to really show a heavy modernist content is not
so much Firebird but more the second if this troika here Petrouchka it's modern
because of the new approach to rhythm in the romantic music that we had been
listening to,
we would hear these long,
somewhat amorphous melodies,
a amorphous in terms of the rhythm.
But now here with the advent of modernism in the 20th century,
we get a much more driving a type of rhythm.
It almost in some ways goes back to the driving rhythms of the baroque except
with one major difference.
And that is that these modern rhythms are highly irregular.
What we get oftentimes are irregular meters.
What would you imagine an irregular meter is?
Anyone want to feel that one?
You regular meters?
Well simply said,
it's not a succession of two,
four,
two,
four two,
four two four three four three,
four but two,
four,
five,
four four four two,
four,
six,
three,
eight and so on.
Each measure can have a different meter.
In addition,
we also have this phenomenon called Polly meters in which you could assign to
your clarinet to play in three,
four and your bassoon to play in four,
four and maybe your violence in [inaudible] 78.
So as a result,
you get something of a disjunctive rhythmic texture here,
disjointed rhythms.
And the second,
second aspect of this,
uh,
approach to modernism has something to do with the orchestration.
There's a great deal more emphasis now on percussive affects.
New Instruments are added to the orchestra instruments called the Xylophone,
the Glockenspiel,
the Celest Sta.
And if you want to see a picture of some of these,
you could open your textbook at some point.
Just write this in your notes.
See figure,
I think I wrote it down here.
Figure 10 you know,
excuse me,
five number 10,
chapter five.
Number 10.
You can see some of these percussion instruments.
But basically they're just either sticks or pieces of metal bars that you beat
with sticks.
Or in the case of the Celestica you activate with a keyboard.
So we've got these two things here,
the driving,
but you irregular rhythms.
And we also have this new approach to orchestration.
So let's listen to a bit now of Igor Stravinsky is ballet of 1911.
Petrouchka
[inaudible]
okay.
So we'll stop there.
Uh,
Jacob and I were fooling around with this in the background,
trying to figure out what these meters we're seeing if we could pick up these
different changes,
but they are as how,
how'd we do not?
Well,
Jacob says we did not do well.
Uh,
because without the score it's difficult to anticipate which meter is going to
come next.
And you heard the intense percussive affects there.
But Stravinsky,
his most radical statement of modernism occurs not here in Petrouchka,
but two years later in the right of springs,
uh,
it premiered in Paris,
in,
uh,
may of 1913 and it's become something of a cultural icon.
This whole idea of the rite of spring.
Indeed.
Uh,
I have this book and I've had it for quite a while.
Rites of Spring by Madras Eckstein.
It's often required reading in the history department here,
history programs.
Anybody ever run into this pedestrian read anything by Modrus Eckstein?
Well,
the is,
you're the great war and the birth of the modern age,
but it's not accidental that he is playing off of this title of a ballet of Igor
Stravinsky because the ballet of Stravinsky was a kind of watershed,
a touchstone.
The benchmark from which modernism,
uh,
can be,
calculated and against which it can be measured.
So when the audience arrive there at the Tiatros shows the lycee,
the auto shows in Esa,
in Paris,
and that theater still is there.
You can walk down the Avenue,
Montana,
it's over that hair,
maize is and Gucci and all of these fancy stores.
It's there in Paris and go in and still hear concerts there.
I've heard concerts in the [inaudible],
so you can still do that today.
It's still functioning as one of the major concert halls in Paris.
So in any event,
May,
1913,
the audience arrives,
they are there to hear a Russian ballet.
What kind of music do they expect to hear?
Well,
let's listen to what they were expecting to hear.
So whose music is this?
Chuck Kowski,
anybody layer,
you know,
the title level,
Swan Lake,
lots of Tutus and potted does up there and moving around.
So this is what they thought.
Russian ballet.
So they arrive.
So they arrive,
let's go in and set up,
uh,
take their seats,
the lights go down,
everybody is properly addressed for this particular occasion.
And here's the kind of music that they hear.
So that's a radically new sound,
radically new approach to modern art.
And indeed,
once again,
if you're asking generally cultural historians to put their finger on the moment
that constitutes the beginning of modernism,
it would probably be this moment of the performance of the,
of the rite of spring.
How did Stravinsky create these radically new sounds?
Well,
he did.
So in a,
in a couple of ways,
uh,
we've,
we've been talking before about this idea of um,
uh,
irregular meters.
Let's see how these play out.
The music that you were just listening to,
not the pitches,
but the durations are up here on the board and they're all,
as you can see,
quarter notes,
but they are grouped in different sorts of ways,
group by these accents.
So I've asked Jacob Jacob's up here to grab his viola.
Now he's going to come over and play this sequence for us following the accents
and then he will be joined by our guest artist.
Okay.
So that's the way it goes.
That's all the,
all the violin or the viola stir violence.
All the strings do.
Let's do that one more time with our guest artists.
We're going to add percussion now.
Yeah.
Ah,
what a virtue.
Okay.
Um,
so that was what Jacob don't go away completely,
uh,
here.
Uh,
one other point,
watch Jacob's hand.
When he is doing this,
this is not the way string players normally play.
He's doing something extra ordinary here.
Okay?
And it tells us,
we don't hear that when you placed your,
He Yadi Yadi Utah,
you duty.
But that's what he's playing now.
Okay.
So what's he doing?
He's playing all with
down bows.
Everything down boat and that's it.
That's counter intuitive district or your normal string teaching.
So run back there if you wouldn't set the slide projector force.
So we've taken the string instruments instead of using them as these warm
virbrato filled communicators,
we're uh,
in the string family.
We're sort of turning them in now to percussion instruments.
That's a very percussive effect.
So not only do we have new percussion instruments,
we have progressive affects with the existing,
uh,
instruments.
Uh,
and uh,
perhaps most important here is the cord,
the music that Stravinsky is setting forth here.
It's an odd odd court.
It's an odd occurrence.
What he's got here is a perfectly innocuous e major triad.
I'll put it down here in October.
And then on top of it,
he's got a seventh chord,
a starting on e flat.
And either each of those each by itself is this rather consonant,
but you put the two of them together.
So this is a good example of another way this modern isn't in music is created
and that's through the use of very obviously a poly cord.
Interesting point.
I'm going to go to some slides now because it's exactly at this time in the
history of art that painters started doing this same kind of thing.
So we're going to go to the first slide here.
Who painted this place?
Nice,
nice and loud.
I hear it in the back.
Picasa.
Okay.
Three by Pablo Picasso.
Uh,
and what we have here is sort of one musician kind of out of phase with himself.
one musician in an another musician,
slightly irregular position against it.
Next type of slide here.
This is,
uh,
George Brock,
a woman that with violin,
a little bit difficult to see the,
um,
the woman there,
but in the context of this highly fragmented violin.
Now we're going to go on the one greys a violin,
and now we're going to go onto a slide taken from a book published in 1916 by,
uh,
Albert Glee's.
Uh,
can you focus that just a little bit?
Forest Jacob,
there's a focus knob up there.
Uh,
go the other way with it.
Oh,
well,
but we can see the,
we can see the point here.
I'm off to the left.
We have just a square and that square then as being rotated against itself,
it's being rotated itself against itself in another position,
rotate it in itself and then not yet another position.
And that's all these musicians are doing.
They're taking one triad and then taking the triad right next to each other so
the triads are slightly out of phase with each other and ultimately it produces
a rather dissonant,
uh,
configuration.
Okay.
That's all we,
that's all we need here.
Uh,
by way of the,
of the slides.
Well,
the premier of the rite of spring was just as dissonant as some of these
paintings are indeed.
It,
it caused a scandal.
It caused a riot.
It was,
it created the most,
uh,
infamous I guess,
riot in the history of music.
And,
uh,
we have,
fortunately,
and they are contained here in modules,
Eckstine's book among other places,
some primary source accounts,
people that were there at the time telling what it was like to be at this
premier.
So here are a couple of direct quotes,
then ensued a battery of screams,
countered by a foil of applause.
We ward over art.
I liked that ward over art or what some thought was art,
but others didn't.
About 40 of the protesters were forced out of the theater by the police,
but that did not quell the disturbance,
the lights in the auditorium or turn fully on.
But that did not still the disjointed ravings of a mob of angry men and women.
Uh,
in quote,
and here's another,
a direct quote.
I was sitting in a box in which I hadn't rented.
One seat.
Three lady sat in front of me and a young man occupied the place behind me.
He stood up during the course of the ballet to see more clearly the intense
excitement under which he was laboring thanks to the potent force of the music
portrayed itself presently when he began to beat rhythmically with his fish on
the top of my head
and quote,
well,
what is it again,
specifically in this music of Stravinsky that causes this kind of reaction?
Let me list for you.
Let me enumerate five things here.
One heavy dissonance.
We just heard some of that,
that kind of sound almost a cluster type dissident heavy dissonance created by
Paulie chords in which we have triads in.
These tribes are only a half step apart.
The roots are only a half step apart.
So one heavy dissonance,
too much greater reliance on percussion,
Timpani,
Glockenspiel,
Celestia,
that sort of thing.
Three,
as we saw with Jacob,
the use of stringed instruments as percussion instrument.
So a new use of these traditional instruments.
And even the piano,
there's banging on the piano to the percussion.
Uh,
it was a piano is technically a percussion instrument,
but so particularly lyrical one.
Well it's not so lyrically used here in the modern idiom number for uh,
an increased use of woodwinds.
The strange fall into the background,
the woodwinds with their potentially bright Riddell sound are now four grounded
and fifth,
uh,
this idea of rhythm driving rhythms.
Yes,
but your regular rhythms and Paula and Polly meters and your regular meters all
creating this kind of disjunctive a affair.
So let's listen now to a passage out of Stravinsky's,
rite of spring.
You heard one of them.
Let's listen to another one in which all five of these elements a sound at once.
What
we have track five.
Oh,
okay.
At 50.
Yes.
Oh,
all right.
That's what I'm sorry.
Let's go ahead then.
[inaudible]
so what do you think?
Do you like that music?
Brian?
You've been a good student here who showed up virtually every lecture.
I see you out there.
What do you think of this?
Just different.
It's different,
more fast paced,
more upbeat,
kind of like a slap in the face.
Uh,
who doesn't like it ended.
Okay.
Caroline.
Caroline on this person out there,
she doesn't like it.
At the end of the day.
Are you going to go home when it's time to relax and put on this music?
Probably not.
Uh,
do I like music?
Yeah,
I really do like this music.
Um,
I love this music,
but I've heard it a lot.
Uh,
and when I first heard it,
I didn't like it.
So the one of these things like sort of oral spinach or whatever,
you've got to really get used to it over over the years.
Mushrooms or whatever it might happen to be.
I first heard this piece in 1967 when I was a ta.
I had to teach it and I didn't really know it.
Uh,
and then I had the honor and pleasure of hearing it performed live in Paris in
1970.
Uh,
and it was really an epiphany because I was sitting there,
I remember it distinctly.
It was in a boxing arena of all places,
but they had an elevated stage and the dancers came out and they started going,
oh,
that kind of thing.
And the whole arena began to shake it.
Whoa.
I now understand.
I get it.
It's not just the music.
Music is just part of this total artistic experience.
It's a kind of sympathetic vibration,
uh,
in conjunction with the kinetic experience of the dance that really brings all
of this to life.
So music here is just a kind of catalyst for the ballet and to really begin to
appreciate something such as this Stravinsky's approached to modernism.
We've kind of,
uh,
we do in fact have to see it to,
to experience it fully.
And that's really what we're going to do here next.
We're going to do that in section starting today.
We have a wonderful video for you of the reconstruction of the rite of spring
because the initial choreography a,
which is an important part of this was lost.
So I'm a woman,
a choreographer came along,
Millicent Hodson,
and she reconstructed all the choreography for this dance and then they filmed
it.
So this is a wonderful opportunity to see this.
We'll be talking about this in a section starting today.
Okay.
We're finished with our brief introduction to modernism and uh,
where do we stand now in our course?
Uh,
well obviously we were pretty much at the end of it.
what do you have to do?
What remains for you to do
Zach?
What you gotta do?
You gotta do your last paper.
Each ta will assign that last paper.
What else do you have to do?
Prepare for the final exam,
we will be sending you a prep sheet.
The final exam I believe is Wednesday the 17th at 2:00 PM and we'll be in this
room.
Other things?
Yeah,
the last six listening exercises.
And I think that's about it.
And of course in addition there's a review section,
uh,
that I and one or two of the TA's will be doing a week from today,
right back,
right back in here.
So,
uh,
is that the end of today?
No,
that's not the end of today.
We have,
uh,
a good half hour left and I'd like to work just with one the piece,
um,
and,
and one composer a at the end of the course.
I'd like to do a piece that's really,
uh,
that I love.
It doesn't really teach you much of anything.
It's an odd sensation.
Oftentimes there are really lovely pieces that I would like to incorporate in
the textbook and in this program generally,
but I can't do it because they don't really teach us anything.
We were listening to one in section just intro music the other day,
uh,
by Samuel Barber.
Anybody know who wrote a famous piece ever?
But did they move that famous piece by Samuel Barber is that is Elizabeth Ral
arou the Adagio for strings by Samuel Barber.
Americans sandwich.
Beautiful.
We should ever,
everybody should download it for 99 cents.
It's just gorgeous.
But we don't really learn anything from,
well,
this is a piece that we,
that we're about to hear,
that we will learn only what really one thing about,
and that is the idea of an orchestral lead.
So I'm going to go back to one of my favorite composers and that is Gustaf
Moller.
We talked a little bit about Gustav Mahler,
uh,
when we had our lecture on the symphony in the 19th century and we said that
Mahler was of Jewish descent from what is now a portion of the Czech Republic
who came into Vienna to study music.
He started as a pianist,
became a conductor,
and basically he earned his living as a conductor.
He got small time jobs out in the provinces and then ultimately worked his way
back to Vienna where he became the conductor of the Staats opera in Vienna.
And if you ever go to Vienna and you should all go to Vienna,
and it's an incredibly musical city.
Everywhere you go,
you see these silhouettes of Mozart.
It is so cool.
So you have to go,
you have to go to,
I mean,
you can't walk a block without seeing Mozart,
it's to die for.
Um,
so there we are on the range Straw.
So with the great Stuart's opera,
and this is where Gustav Mahler conducted,
it's still there.
Um,
but Mahler was a difficult person to get along with.
I suppose.
Oftentimes great artists are geniuses are,
they tend to be self referential and maybe rightly so.
Uh,
but in any event,
he was an orchestral tyrant.
His players didn't like playing for them.
And after 10 years they didn't renew his contract.
In effect,
he was fired in Vienna,
but as good fortune had it,
he,
um,
uh,
was able,
or that time there was an opening in New York City.
So he comes to New York to conduct first the metropolitan opera.
And then a year or so later he took on what was to become the New York
Philharmonic.
So there he is the principal conductor.
Now in New York City.
Interestingly enough,
uh,
on two occasions,
Mahler,
um,
came to new haven.
He came to new haven.
He brought a first was in 1910 he brought the New York Philharmonic to new
haven.
And where,
where did they perform?
Where would you imagine they perform?
Woolsey.
Hall.
Okay.
Woolsey Hall Woolsey Hall was built for Gustav Mahler.
No,
that's not really true,
but it gets across the point that Woolsey Hall was built to be a concert hall
for what Gustaf Moller represented,
which was the apotheosis the ultimate flourishing,
although they didn't know what was the ultimate at the time of this great
instrument,
which was the 19th century orchestra.
So Mahler brings the New York Philharmonic to Woolsey Hall.
Next time you're in Woolsey Hall,
think of Gustaf Moller standing on those boards there.
And as good luck would have it again,
it was reviewed in of all places.
As you can see by the handout for today.
Dot.
Um,
the Yale daily.
Okay.
How about that?
The daily reviews Gustaf Moller astonishing.
Okay.
Astonishing.
And I didn't darn it,
I didn't bring my glasses today,
but you can sort of look at the,
look at the review there.
Uh,
and it talks about the repertoire.
What,
uh,
what did he,
what did he perform?
First of all,
they slightly misspelled his name.
There's no e on Gustaf and the way he spelled it,
but that doesn't really matter.
Um,
what did they perform at this concert conducted by Mahler in Woolsey Hall?
What's it say there,
Elizabeth?
Okay.
Sound phony.
Fantastic.
The basis of what you're listening.
Exercise 34.
Okay,
so that was one of the big pieces are ones that you have just engaged.
What else please?
Okay.
Bach orchestral suite doesn't say which one,
doesn't matter.
What else?
Yeah,
that's good.
Until oil and Spiegel's Mary Pranks.
That's another one of these tone poems like Zara through stress and like death
and transfiguration by Strauss.
And there was also,
um,
a,
a pianist there.
And what did she perform all Olga summer off
the Grieg piano concerto,
but no music by Mahler because in his,
uh,
day,
Mahler was thought to really be more of a conductor,
a conductor than he was a composer.
We'll come back to that point in a minute.
The second time that Mahler came to new haven was the next year,
1911.
He went to what was then called new haven hospital.
Why?
Because he had a heart condition.
Uh,
and I gather and we have in our Mitch today a specialist who can talk to this
more directly than I,
um,
a streptococcal infection,
a lingering streptococcal infection in the area of the heart,
uh,
that had greatly weakened his heart.
Uh,
so the doctors at Yale New Haven Hospital in new haven,
hospital's,
there's really nothing we can do for you.
He goes back to New York,
it goes immediately back to Vienna and he dies within six weeks of this heart
condition.
And we have,
and I'm delighted to say Dr. Jean James Hines has been with us all semester.
Jim,
thank you for your attendance.
Uh,
a cardiologist can use been here.
You may thought that this was just accidental,
but in case I was thinking this morning,
uh,
we'd never told you that we had,
if your heart begins to palpitate when you're listening to all this really great
music and you become aphasic or something,
like,
we have an attendant here ready to serve you in the form of doctor height.
So you've been in good hands all along.
And thank you Jim,
for,
for being here.
Uh,
so,
uh,
let's take a look at some of the things that Gustafsson Wall are composed here.
I think we've got a list up on the board.
Okay.
Uh,
symphonies nine symphonies.
Why is everybody composes nine symphonies and then they die.
Uh,
I stop at eight a company he composed also nine symphonies.
He composed nine symphonies.
Um,
and if you like Mauler and I hope you will come to light.
[inaudible].
Uh,
I think there's an entry path into these symphonies.
Start with number four.
It's the most user friendly.
Then number one,
we played s extra x out of number one in that symphony lecture.
So,
you know,
that's,
it's a great piece to then a symphony number five,
which is worth the price of admission.
Really,
uh,
if for no other reason then the middle movement there,
that Adagietto it's just so heartbreakingly beautiful that no one would want to
miss it.
And then ultimately a little bit more challenging,
symphonies,
bigger symphonies,
a number eight,
and number nine.
Mauler also wrote,
as you can see up there,
two collections of songs they're called,
or Kestrel leader.
We have this term or Kestrel elite simply means orchestral song.
Uh,
we've had the lead before in our course,
uh,
where indeed,
what was the name of the lead that we work
with?
Composer's name.
The name of the piece.
Hmm.
Okay.
Well that's it.
That's it.
What,
what was the name of the piece?
Elf King.
Thank you Fredrik.
And who has the composure?
Franz Schubert.
Okay.
So we've had a,
that's,
that's a lead for piano,
but now we have a lead for voice and orchestra.
So it tends to be bigger and more flamboyant.
This is unusual.
It's longer,
it's more colorful,
yet it features a single voice singing a,
uh,
a single,
a single text.
So we're going to focus on now on one of of Gustav Mahler's or Kestrel,
uh,
leads.
Um,
and it's talked about in the textbook there,
uh,
right before impressionism,
no listening exercise on it.
And as I say,
it's in there just because I think it's a drop dead beautiful piece.
And I want to try to proselytize bit with regard to Muller's music.
So it has a text.
Here's the text.
The text is by romantic,
a German poet,
Friedrich Rueckert.
We're now talking about,
uh,
it had been their belt [inaudible] Coleman by Friedrich Bruker as set in this
collection of five songs,
about 19 Oh 1902 and 1802.
Um,
and let's take a look at the German here.
Just for a moment.
It had been their belt up hand and go Coleman.
I become detached from the world.
Um,
and uh,
I thought it might be nice to hear,
um,
a German speaker or somebody that speaks pretty good German,
uh,
tackle this tech.
So I've asked a student,
David the Roski cope and to stand up if you would,
um,
uh,
David's applying to med school,
right?
You're going around with all kinds of med school interviews,
but he's putting on his German hat for us,
uh,
this morning.
So read the first a stroll fee please,
David.
Okay.
And let's cut to the last one and a little bit more slowly and the lymph because
it slows down.
So let's,
let's read it a little more slowly.
He's speeding.
This job
student,
you'd beads each lab align in minor in mining even in mine and lead.
Okay,
great.
Thanks very much.
So as you can see here,
uh,
this is in a sense old person's music in that this is an individual that has
become disenchanted,
is exhausted from the trials and tribulations of this,
of this world is it says that he had been their belt up.
Hondan good Coleman.
I've become detached from the world.
And if you don't see much of me anymore,
I don't really care because as it says in the last trophy,
it been distorb under [inaudible].
I'm dead to the trauma,
I guess of the world in who and is still in beat.
And I rest now in a still land,
uh,
labor line.
I'm living alone in my heaven in minded Lieben in mine and lead.
And there where it's an interesting play of the word lead because it's not so
much a song.
This is a metaphor for all of his music.
So this is an individual that has become detached from the world and simply
wants to live in the world of music.
So let's listen to a bit of it now.
Um,
and it starts out with an English horn.
Somebody tell us,
review for us what an English horn is.
Talked about this before Jerry.
A lower Obo.
That's right.
A lower oh bone.
It sounds a little bit more and full.
Sounds a little bit nostalgic here.
So we'll here lovely harp underneath.
And then the English horn,
we'll start just one phrase and then the phrase will grow.
It's kind of a cell or a motive growing into a longer melody as we discussed at
the beginning of the course.
Whoops.
Uh,
we need,
let's see.
Track too.
It's okay
of the,
of,
of the red CD.
Okay.
No,
no.
Let's see.
It should be,
have been the single CD that was in here.
It should be city far as shirts.
That in there
too of what it should be.
CD three.
Okay.
Sorry.
That's,
it's that red one there.
Yeah.
Okay.
How many cds do we have?
The thing where it won't
change all the way.
Okay.
Um,
let's shut it,
shut it down then and then see if we can get back to that CD and it should be
tracked to have that,
that CD.
Sometimes our CD player eats our cds.
That's gets it up there and it won't release them.
So we'll have to reconfigure this.
Um,
it's an interesting a song in that I'm going to van peer just for a moment.
We've,
it starts out with,
with the harp underneath and the English horn and it's a movement in which there
is no brass whatsoever.
So I believe we have it set up now.
It's not to be an exciting movement.
A much more reflective movement
passes off the melody to a clarinet
and then the voice will come in.
We're gonna pause it there.
Then we will go on to a little bit of material from the climax of the song.
Just by way of a preview here,
we're going to go on now two oh four 47 if you,
if you will,
uh,
where he works up to a peak on this text.
He can labor line in mind and hemo in,
in [inaudible],
in mind,
in lead.
Little bit of dissonance
back to the tonic.
English born comes back in,
builds out the melody.
Okay,
now we're going to pause it here because there's one other small point I want to
make and that has to do with a,
what's called a suspension.
The suspension is something that composure set up in music to sort of make us
feel a particular way and they'll start with this by having a note,
be consonant
and then having moving the harmony underneath of it to a dissonance and then
resolving it to a constant like that.
Or maybe,
and the longer they sit on the dissonance,
the more feeling I think is,
is communicated.
And here at the end of the romantic period,
it tends to be,
they tend to sit on these dissonances inside of the suspension for a long period
of time.
So we're about to hear will we still got it right there.
We're about to hear the strings go up and play a suspension.
And then the English horn,
we'll do the same.
There it is.
Now the English horn will suspend
dissonance.
Okay,
so that's the piece.
Now we're going to do something.
We've only done one other occasion in our class and that is the list of the
whole piece from beginning to end.
I'd like to do this.
I'm even a little hokey I guess,
but it doesn't matter.
It can turn off all the lights here as best I can.
And I do this because it gives you a sense sometimes of what,
at least how I engage music oftentimes.
What does it do for us?
Well,
we've talked before at the beginning.
It allows us to kind of relax,
center our attention.
You're under a lot of stress at the moment.
This is a,
the sort of climax crunch time in the academic world.
So this is an opportunity to kind of tune everything out.
Maybe go inside of your own beat here,
your own musical territory.
Uh,
and maybe think of things in the past.
Music is a creator of Nostalgia.
Think of things that might be music.
Uh,
uh,
giving us a vision.
Perhaps have a better world,
a whatever you would like to ever spend you want to put on this.
But we're going to be,
each of us is now going to go into our own zone here for about seven minutes as
we listened to this orchestral lead had been developed on Hung Coleman by Gustav
Mahler.
Eh,
it's fine.
Hey,
Ooh,
Yay.
Okay.
Hey
hmm.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Oh,
oh,
I am.
Okay.
So that's our last piece of music at four.
Listening to music here.
Now I'm going to tell you what this class was really about.
It wasn't about listening to music.
It was about saving classical music,
saving classical music.
Why?
Why would we want to save classical music?
We could spend hours discussing that.
We would want to save it,
arguably,
because it is one of
the things that we value in western culture.
What are we valuers and he about this,
this morning we've got,
we just had a big election,
right?
We value democracy.
We value religious freedom.
We value quality of the sexes,
of gender.
What else?
A due process under the law.
We Value Shakespeare.
We Value Leonardo Davinci and the symphonies of Mozart,
for example.
Uh,
and these are very important things.
I think they're worth,
worth fighting for and worth trying to,
trying to preserve.
Recently somebody gave the school of music.
How much money?
$100 million to keep classical music alive.
That's a lot of money.
I've done my part.
Showed up here everyday.
Haven't missed a minute.
Now it's time for you to do your part.
What's your part?
You have to do the following kinds of things.
You have to continue to buy cds and download classical music,
uh,
off of iTunes or whatever it is.
Don't steal that stuff.
Why?
If you take that stuff for nothing,
what are you doing?
You're taking the livelihood away from Jacob and Santana and uh,
Linda here.
There,
there's the livelihood is musicians.
They've put their Labor into it and you're taking it for nothing.
So download these things.
It doesn't cost all that much to get involved.
Get involved in informal singing groups,
keep your piano lessons.
Have you ever had those kinds of things going on,
local choral groups,
whatever you get out of Yale,
what do you do?
Get on the boards of these artistic institutions,
your local symphony,
your local choral society,
Opera Company,
Neighborhood Music School here.
Get on the board of that and help them.
Those sorts of folks.
Most important give music lessons to your children.
Adopted or,
or natural.
Why teaches them hard work?
Teaches them to think sequentially,
teaches them various forms of quantitative reasoning.
Teaches them also,
uh,
to be disciplined and teaches them to,
have a,
a pride in the work product that they,
that they ultimately ultimately generate.
So these are the kinds of things that,
that you can do.
I thank you for your attention.
I thank you.
I think the Tas for doing such a wonderful,
we've had great TA's this year.
And,
uh,
I will end by quoting,
thanking you for,
for allowing me to quote here.
Uh,
Gustaf Moller once again to share with you.
Mine and Lieben might've lead because it really is.
Thanks very much.